On the work of Khan Academy
Let's practice several experiments.
We have been collecting here
we'll get round numbers.
These numbers are exactly divisible by either 10 or 100.
Now let's look at it here. We add 427 to 63,
it may seem tough to you.
At first glance, though we may be able to calculate and write them down,
but I just took a few units from them,
I'm adding another
and in this case both are rounded numbers,
If I get 3 units of 63, then 60
and if I add that 3 units to 427,
I'll get 430 and 60 plus 430
it is solved very simply.
Now, let's see what this question is about us.
This example shows us step by step
and it asks us that there are 63 plus 427 examples
(Plus 60 plus), plus 427?
So, how many are actually 60 plus
May be 63,
There are 427 on both sides, 63 in this case plus 60 plus 3.
We have already seen a result here.
At the next stage, simply their order has changed.
(Plus 60 plus three) plus 427
As a result
60 plus (three plus 427).
So we have three figures
From 63 to 427 we are adding.
So, three plus 427 equals 430.
Now, this collection operation has become easier.
60 plus 430, we can count it in our brains.
We're just adding six decimal places here,
and we get 490, which is the result.
Let's work with some examples.
So we're here
we will collect these two numbers.
For this, take them
round
in this case, we
275 numbers are 270 and the total number of digits.
This is plus 270 plus five.
Look, the other part is the same,
plus 595, plus 595
Now, what are we doing for this?
If we bought five of 275 units and added up to 595
just as we did now,
595 will be 600.
In this case, calculation becomes easier.
Let's take a look again. Here's the first one
270 plus five and later plus 595
but we can change the order here
we are adding the first to five of 595
then we add 270.
This is the result
270 plus five plus 595 equal to 600.
The whole purpose was bought from 275 to five units
Adding to 595 was about 600.
We can count it in our brains
270 plus six hundred
that is, multiplying by 100 six times, and ultimately the answer is 870.
Let's work on a few more examples
Fill empty field.
51 plus 83 equals plus 84
There are a total of 83 pieces here.
in this case, we reduce the size of 51 units,
resulting in 50 plus 84.
Why should everyone know that?
Why do they do it?
Actually, I can easily figure this out,
because I simply say
eight plus nine plus four plus plus five others
this is 13 decimal and four loneliness or 134.
This is easier for me.
but the most important issue is if we have any number in one number
If you add, you have to deduce the same number of numbers.
This is the law of the place of assembly
it is basically the same. When changing the place, the jam does not change.
Let's make another example.
138 plus 710 equal to plus 700
It was 710, now it is 700
we have 10 units of that number.
we have to add another number that we received.
138 and more 10
It is 148.
What is the advantage of this?
148 plus 700 operations in our brains,
We get 848 responses to calculate this way
it's easier than calculating here.